je vais rebondir sur votre question
suivante le risque de délestage cet
hiver puisque malheureusement et vous
l'avez dit les réseaux télécoms ne sont
pas de par la loi concernant les sites
critiques qui a été défini en fait avant
l'arrivée des réseaux télécoms dans les
années 90 les sites télécoms ne sont pas
jugés comme étant des sites prioritaires
alors en fait dans les dans les réseaux
télécoms il y a différents types de
sites et donc certains de nos sites sont
effectivement priorisés dans les plans
de prévention pour la préparation que
nous mettons en oeuvre à des risques de
délestage mais une partie de nos sites
en particulier les dizaines de milliers
de sites mobiles et c'est un sujet que
nous adressons nous orange mais avec
l'ensemble de nos concurrents et avec la
Fédération des télécoms la dizaine de
milliers de sites mobiles ne sera pas
priorisé de même que nos clients et un
certain nombre de nos sites critiques
dans le réseau qui sont équipées de
opérateur et de batterie ne seront pas
non plus priorisées donc il y a des
systèmes de secours qui permettront de
prendre le relais néanmoins si les
délaissages se multiplient on ne sait
pas en fait comment comportera le réseau
et ce que l'on appelle un site critique
dans les infrastructures télécomes ce
sont des sites qui impactent et peuvent
avoir un impact au niveau national pour
le réseau puisqu'effectivement on parle
de délestage qui seront régionaux et on
s'organise on fait des exercices en
partenariat en partenariat et en bonne
entente j'allais dire entre opérateur
avec le gouvernement évidemment enedis
on a fait un certain nombre d'exercices
de crises c'est un sujet sur lequel
orange alerte orange et la Fédération
alerte le gouvernement depuis le début
de l'année 2022 en fait depuis qu'on a
été prévenus de risque de délestage
c'est un sujet sur lequel on continue de
travailler mais je crains que nos
concitoyens et les Français découvrent
que les réseaux télécom dépendent
d'électricité
et qu'il est absolument impossible car
cela prendrait plus de 5 ans
d'imaginer si tenter que ce soit
finançable et compatible avec nos
objectifs environnementaux également il
est illusoire d'imaginer mettre des
batteries au pied de chacun des sites
mobiles en France